Alright, I'd like you to take a moment.
Think about a time when you
were recently sick.
Try specifically to think of a time when,
even though you weren't
feeling all that great,
you still felt well enough
to get up out of bed,
go about your day.
OK, what was your mood like?
Did you feel a little sad or depressed?
What types of social interactions
did you want to have?
Would you have wanted to go
to a cocktail party full of strangers
or out on a first date?
I'm a psychology professor
at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill,
and for the past 15 years,
I've been studying the interconnections
between physiological changes
happening in the body during sickness
and psychological and social well-being.
Specifically my lab studies
social psychoneuroimmunology,
which is a mouthful to say,
and is a field of research
that's dedicated
to discovering interactions between
our social experiences,
psychological processes
and the immune system.
Today, I want to tell you
about some research showing
that the same physiological changes
happening in your body
that cause the physical symptoms
you have when you're sick,
are also shaping your mood
and your social behavior.
In other words, changes
in the immune system
can signal to the brain
to cause us to think,
feel and act differently.
And not only that, but also our social
experiences can cause changes
in our immune systems.
So purely psychological things
happening in our brains
can cause the immune system
to ramp up or ramp down.
Because of that, we can get caught
in these vicious cycles
where our psychological experiences
can cause changes in our immune system,
and those immunological shifts
can cause changes
to our psychological experiences.
Now the component of the immune system
that most research in psycho-
neuroimmunology focuses on
is the inflammatory response
or inflammation.
The inflammatory response
is your immune system's
first line of defense
against injury or infection,
and it's coordinated by these molecules
that are called
pro-inflammatory cytokines.
You can think of cytokines
as sort of the chemical messengers
of the immune system.
So they're out there right now,
swimming through your bloodstream.
And if an immune cell finds
something weird or out of the ordinary,
they'll tell those cytokines
to signal to other immune cells
to come and check it out.
So if you think about a time
you've had a paper cut,
you may have noticed
that the area around the cut swells,
it turns red, it heats up.
That's the inflammatory
response in action.
And those symptoms are caused
by your cytokines doing their job,
sending out signals to other immune
cells to come and heal the cut.
The same thing happens
if your immune cells find a virus
or a bacteria in the body.
They send out cytokines
to signal to other immune cells
to come and try
and eliminate the pathogen.
Now in doing this, cytokines cause
the physical symptoms
we commonly have when we're sick.
Things like fever
and achiness and fatigue.
So even though we usually think of those
symptoms as being caused by a virus
or a bacteria itself,
they're actually caused
by our own immune systems
activating to try
to eliminate the pathogen.
But in addition to those
physical symptoms,
decades of research,
in both animals and humans,
clearly shows that cytokines
also cause changes to our mood
and to our social behavior.
So inflammation in the body
can signal to the brain
to cause us to feel down,
depressed and even hopeless.
Inflammation can also make us want
to socially withdraw from other people
to avoid interacting with individuals
in our social networks.
So this research shows the powerful
influence that the immune system can have
on our mood and on our social behavior.
Changes in inflammation in the body
can signal to the brain to cause us
to feel depressed and even lonely.
OK, so you may be wondering,
why on Earth would your body do this?
Why would you want your immune system
to be able to manipulate your brain
and cause you to feel sad and distant
from other people in your life?
While we can't know for sure
why this happens,
evolutionary theory provides
some good food for thought.
The fact is,
revving up and running the immune
system takes a lot of energy.
Getting cytokines to swim
through the bloodstream
and send signals to immune
cells takes calories.
And what else takes calories?
Pretty much everything.
Especially things like going out
and seeking pleasurable experiences,
interacting with strangers
and just generally moving about the world.
So the theory is that the immune system
is telling the brain to feel depressed
and to withdraw from socializing
because it wants you
to stay at home and rest.
And if things that would
normally sound fun
just don't seem all that fun,
and if interacting with other
people seems exhausting
and maybe even a little threatening,
then we'll be less likely
to do those things
and more likely to stay at home
and let our immune systems
use our calories.
Now, of course, if this becomes prolonged
and inflammation is elevated over weeks
or even years,
that could have really terrible
impacts on our well-being.
But in the short term,
we think of this immune-to-brain
signaling as adaptive.
Your immune system is basically good
at knowing when it would be a good idea
for you to be out interacting
with the world and the people in it,
and when it would be better
to just stay at home.
But it turns out, the influence
of inflammation on our social lives
isn't as simple as always
making us feel more disconnected
and socially withdrawn.
One of the most important discoveries
that we've made in this area
of research recently
is that inflammation might actually
make us more motivated
to seek some social interactions,
specifically those with the people
who we're closest to.
So it’s not that inflammation
makes us less social across the board,
it may just make us more selective
about who we want to socialize with.
To discover this, my colleagues
and I ran an experiment.
We asked participants in our study
to send us digital photographs
of someone who they could go to
if they needed help or support.
As you would expect, people sent us
photos of their romantic partners,
their closest friends and their family.
Then we had our participants view
those images of their support figure
while we tracked their brain activity
using MRI scanning.
Now, critically, prior to the MRI scans,
we exposed a random half
of the participants in our study
to a bacteria which cause levels
of inflammation in the body to increase.
The other half just had normal,
low levels of inflammation.
And what we found is that for the people
who we exposed to that bacteria,
who had lots of cytokines in their body,
they actually showed more activity
in a reward-related region of the brain,
called the ventral striatum,
when they viewed images
of their support figures
relative to the people who had
low levels of inflammation.
So what this suggests
is that while inflammation might make
social interactions with strangers
seem less rewarding,
it doesn't necessarily make all social
interactions seem less rewarding.
In fact, inflammation may make us
more motivated to seek interactions
with people who could provide us
with comfort or care.
Those who could be a shortcut
to chicken soup.
But of course, it's not every day
that we come into contact
with a virus or a bacteria,
or that we have a wound
that causes our levels
of inflammation to increase.
So how much of a day-to-day
influence on our social lives
does the immune system actually have?
Research shows that the answer
is a lot more than you might think.
That's because one
of the most robust findings
in all of psychoneuroimmunology research
is that stress causes inflammation.
So purely psychological
things happening in the brain
can cause increases
in cytokines in the body.
This is true across species,
from rodents to primates to humans.
In my lab and in others across the globe,
we study the effects of stress
on inflammation
by asking people to come
into the lab and give a ten-minute,
off-the-cuff speech
about why they'd be a good
candidate for their dream job.
And then they have to do challenging
mental math out loud.
And they do this all in front of a panel
of experts who's judging them.
Yeah, people report
that this is stressful.
And critically,
in response to this psychologically
stressful experience,
we see that levels of cytokines
in the body have increased.
Let's take a second and really appreciate
that remarkable finding.
In the absence of anything physically
wrong with the body --
no viruses, no bacteria, no wounds --
a purely psychological stressor
is causing the inflammatory
response to activate.
So it's not just that our immune systems
are sending signals to our brain,
but also our brains are sending signals
to our immune systems
telling them to activate in response
to stress that we encounter.
OK, so now that you know
that your immune system
has this very active social life
and that your brain and your immune system
are constantly communicating
in ways that could make you feel
depressed or lonely,
what should you do?
For me, knowing about the social life
of the immune system
has changed my life,
in part because it gives me an explanation
for why I might feel physically crummy
at the end of a stressful day,
or why I might feel a little down
and disconnected from other people
when I'm feeling physically unwell.
So, for example,
the experience of giving this talk today
has been really rewarding
and also quite challenging.
You might even say it was,
at times, stressful.
And I'm sure you've had similar
experiences in your lives.
Maybe it was a difficult task
you had to complete at work,
a confrontation with a spouse
or a family member,
or just some problem
that cropped up in your life
that you had to quickly
figure out how to solve.
Based on what I've told you here today,
I hope you're predicting that in response
to these stressful experiences,
we're likely to have high levels
of inflammation in our bodies.
Our cytokines will
have come out in full force
in response to the stress
we've experienced.
And because of that,
if we then feel exhausted
and a bit like we've failed
and we don't want to go anywhere
or see anyone or do anything,
and we just want to stay at home
and relax on the couch
with the people who we're closest to,
we'll know why.
And because we know that those symptoms
are likely just our immune systems
telling our brains to feel depressed
and to withdraw from social interactions
so that we stay at home to rest,
relax and recuperate,
we don't have to agonize
over why we're maybe feeling
a little down on ourselves,
or a little distant from other people.
We can rest assured that
in the coming days,
we'll be feeling much more
like ourselves again
as our cytokine levels go back down.
So in the future,
when you encounter stress in your life
and you feel those reins
of inflammation start to take hold,
I hope you remember
what I've told you here today.
And you remind yourself that those
symptoms you're experiencing,
that's likely just your immune system
doing its job,
telling your brain to feel
depressed and withdrawn
as evolution intended,
to keep you healthy in the long term.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)